brettspiele wie das hier kennt jeder
monopoly ich meine die idee ist ja schon
echt genial und es gibt auch noch ganz
viele andere wie mensch ärgere dich
nicht oder das ich mir wie steht es
eigentlich selber irgendwie so eine idee
zu haben wie schwer ist es selbst im
brettspiel zu machen mit mitteln die hat
jeder so zu hause hat am freitag also
ungefähr fünf tagen finden wir uns im
brettspiel anstatt und bis dahin wenn
ich mein eigenes bereits verständigt
haben und ihr werdet am ende auch testen
können aber wie verrate ich euch später
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist
[Musik]
mal schauen was so ein brettspiel
eigentlich ausmacht
angefangen mit dem klassiker monopoly
also man braucht ein spielbrett ist
schon mal klar als ich eine spiegeln
währung das natürlich auch wichtig
spielfiguren würfel und ich glaube diese
fünf eigenschaften die haben fast alle
von diesen spielen
[Musik]
also dass wir willens schwierig weiß auf
jeden fall dass ich ein brettspiel will
mir den feldern auf denen man umgehen
kann und dass man diese bewegungen im
würfel steuert ich bin würfel unserem
glück faktor generell mal cool weil man
dann hat einfach nie weiß wie es
ausgehen und immer ein bisschen noch
alles offen bleibt aber bevor ich jetzt
ein spielfeld designer muss ich mir
überlegen ob es jetzt mittelalter oder
irgendwie zukunft oder zauberer sein
soll aber die ganzen brettspiele hier
sind eigentlich also mittelalter
zauberer mäßig und das finde ich
eigentlich auch schon echt cool 89 die
linse ist gebrochen ich entscheide mich
für einen stil aus sechsecken und die
schattierungen bestehen ebenfalls aus
sechsecken es gibt gras erde stein und
schnee irgendwie erinnert mich das von
der reihenfolge fast an einen berg mit
schnee am gipfel ein vulkan wer aber
auch cool also mache ich lieber was
damit genau passieren soll keine ahnung
ich erstelle ein raster und ordnen die
einzelnen felder damit zu einem kleinen
vulkan und erstelle eine grasfläche
drumherum die welt erschaffen auf diese
art und weise relativ lange dauert mache
ich an die lustiges gibt's zu in
photoshop langsam entsteht erst ein
vulkan dann wird das ganze durch einen
strand und dann wasser zu einer insel an
den grund hat das aber nicht das ist
einfach so entstanden ich muss mir also
hinterher überlegen was man auf dieser
insel so tolles machen kann es entsteht
ein kleiner weg viele anläufe aber
letztendlich bin ich damit sehr
zufrieden nur das hat mich jetzt bis
hierher alleine zwei tage gedauert
also optisch findet das ganze jetzt
eigentlich schon mega ist wirklich aber
ich hab noch keinen plan was man dann
halt jetzt machen soll dann sage ich
druck ist ganz einfach mal aus clips auf
pappe und hofft dass mir dann irgendwie
in der deckung so ein riesiges
spielbrett kann man normale drucker
jetzt natürlich nicht auf einmal drucken
aber man kann in der software auch ein
riesiges zusammengesetztes bild drucken
aufgeteilt auf mehrere din a 4 blätter
und auch wenn das jetzt kein schickes
fotopapier oder ähnliches ist sieht das
schon echt cool aus finde ich wie meine
kreation hier zum leben erweckt und
realität wird
zu geben das richtig schön herr es sieht
schon voll aus wie ein spiel voll cool
so jetzt müssen aber erstmal
ausschneiden und
anschließend auf papier jetzt
draufkleben
die ganzen großen bekannten brettspiel
haben ja immer so ein mega abgefahrenen
fall mechanismus mit dem anhalt auf
kleinsten platz ein riesiges bretting
kriegt ja und das muss ich jetzt eben
auch schaffen und ich sage ich mal
zweifel natürlich dann auch zusammen
er wurde ja auch keinen druck nun als
überhaupt nicht funktioniert kann wie
das passieren konnte ich muss jetzt
einfach mal irgendwie zusammen isst ihn
unter ist je nach ihr braucht man
wirklich mega
flop da ist es doch gesagt dass sie den
also die eine idee wäre halt irgendwie
diese territorien aufbauen kann und dann
irgendwelche dinge auch bestimmte größen
platzieren kann vielleicht gibts sogar
noch irgendwie ortete die irgendwie
besser für irgendwas sind wir es gibt es
noch verschiedene grünen farben oder so
von den 61 hat er schon ziemlich aus wie
siedler von catan oder so also wenn ich
das nicht machen ich habe mir schon
überlegt dass es dem so ein bisschen
piraten mäßig ist könnte sein dass es
hier verschiedene xl gibt
dann gibt es zufällig manche experten
ist nichts und dann aber das ist mein
rennen verteilt dann ist manchen etwas
voll geil ist runter runter man ihnen
einfach nicht oder ist das jetzt habe
ich die idee und dann hat aber solch
eine depots auch das ist natürlich geil
wenn das genau so ist das halt die stadt
verteilt sind einen festen sportsmann
keiner weise am anfang wo diese aber es
gibt gewisse ereignis felder wo dann
halt steht ja auch du darfst eine der
karten umdrehen wie würdest du es gerne
vielleicht gehört dass mit dem ex
schatz mit ex das war wohl nix oha herr
das ist ja voll geil der name er das ist
übel das schon in
arbeit
gesagt getan mittlerweile ist auch so
ein fancy fotopapier am start
dann würde ich sagen damit sie sich doch
jetzt mal direkt aus dem pc
[Musik]
jetzt noch mal die dinge ausgedruckt die
xl das hat dann oftmals nicht so gut
geklappt wie zum beispiel wie zb hier
kann man so eigentlich laden bringen er
ist das wären dann so plättchen die man
dann darauf linken genau also vielleicht
ein stück papier dazwischen das ist
dicker wird glaube wir haben ende wenn
halt alle schatz ist ja ein gesammelt
sind am meisten schatzkiste hat der hat
dann
würdest du es dann auch so machen dass
man quasi wenn der cmx ist zum beispiel
dass man auf das feld drauf muss in
deren haus nur leicht aus dann ist
verlust ich habe dann in den jahren
verschiedene leute da rumstehen und das
stand besuchen so zu malen ist es nicht
und dann muss da jeder dreimal bis ein
paar schade oder nicht wie bei monopoly
oder nicht aus dem gefängnis kommt ja
ewig und dann kriegt vor der partie als
erster startete
comvel von
für von werfen bist du abschneiden ich
will helfen dass mit aufgeschaltet hier
kleber
[Musik]
schiebe ding
ding ding
[Musik]
die stadtfelder werden erst sortiert
einen teil davon entfernt und der rest
wird umgedreht und blind gemischt wenn
die schatz fällt er dann auf dem
spielbrett platziert sind weiß niemand
ob er nun gerade eine sieges
entscheidende schatztruhe ausgräbt mit
zehn gold to go on vertröstet wird oder
mit extrem viel pech ganz einfach in die
luft gehen
das spiel ist zu ende wenn der letzte
schatz geborgen wurde und gewonnen hat
der mit den meisten schatzkisten das
ziel steht also fest aber damit der weg
dahin möglichst lustig und spannend ist
braucht es noch einige kleine
mechanismen die dem spiel die würze
verleihen
um 11 gd brettspiel abend los jetzt
gerade 19 und 30 das heißt ich habe noch
dreieinhalb schon uns erhält umkommt
unfertiges spiel komplett fertig zu
machen ich hab noch kein regelwerk noch
keine spielfiguren ich hab auch gar
nichts
[Musik]
jene spielbereit ist komplett fertig was
jetzt noch fehlt sind spielfiguren und
nehmen es natürlich auch in 3d drucker
entstehen wir haben zwei stunden also
letztendlich was ein schlauer gewesen
die schon vorher zu machen aber
[Musik]
mein büro verwandelt sich in eine
werkstatt ach was sage ich eine fabrik
jeder packt mit an und schneidet karten
aus verklebt pappe oder bemalt die
spielfiguren mit nagellack weil das
paket mit der richtigen farbe beim
nachbarn abgegeben wurde und erst viel
zu spät wäre jetzt noch zu klingeln um
23 uhr mittlerweile läuft der drucker
auf seiner dritten tintenpatrone und
wird ständig fehler aber letztendlich
kann selbst dass die maschinerie nicht
zum stoppen bringen
ja also ich mitgemacht habe
aber bevor ich jetzt den namen verrate
muss ich erst mal erklären wie es
funktioniert jeder spieler ist ein pirat
der auf einem floß gestrandet ist
nachdem alle schätze verdeckt auf dem
spielfeld aufgeteilt sind weiß niemand
ob sich darunter eine begehrte
schatztruhe nur etwas gold oder mit viel
pech sogar eine unerwünschte bombe
befindet
dieses misstrauen ist ja und jetzt
geht's los jetzt würfeln und man erstmal
schritte gehen wir haben hier die vulkan
und dagegen die jedem zug geht der einst
erhoben und wenn es auch sechs ist da
explodierte halt und wenn ja wo kann
explodiert da muss man fünf schritte
zurück gehen in die richtung aus sehr
gelungen und der der am ende die meisten
schätze hat hat man gewonnen ab dem
moment wenn er keine schätzung meer zu
bergen sind da muss halt würfeln so oft
bis man mit der augenzahl den counter
von diesem schatz auf 15 hoch gemacht
hat das ist in dem fall so dass man so
nach dem schatz gräbt das hat natürlich
auch das halt wenn du jetzt schon auf
zehn hoch gebracht hast dann unten
andere noch reinkommt dass der denn als
netten kann derjenige alter unter 15
halbzeit rein und krieg es gibt noch
andere zwei bomben gefälligst den schatz
im hass zudem gibt es aktionsfelder bei
denen man eine aktions karte ziehen muss
wettkampf felder bei denen jeder fünf
gold jubeln einsetzen muss und
anschließend ausgewürfelt wird wer den
gesamten einsatz bekommt und noch mehr
aber also es ist auch gerade 81 glaube
wir alle wollen spielen
[Musik]
das haben gedacht
am 12
[Musik]
das active noise und hat noch eine
chance traurig
bin jetzt 46 wirklich kriegt oder
sich schon bitter oder wenn man so die
ganze zeit darauf erste war und die
ganze zeit
ruhig kommen wir einfach nachricht ich
waren uns nichts mehr
keine bombe
und das ist kein scherz so also ja dass
die bauern weltweit blöd und jetzt hat
geht weiter und das ist lustig ist hat
jetzt hat jetzt wo angesammelt dass mir
jetzt halt im festlich verlauf des
spiels nicht mal so sagen hoffentlich
wird es hier auch teilen also
aktionskarten
spiele deiner wahl selbst nicht helfen
will ich muss sagen du weil du am
meisten hasst
gucken sie nach unten
im schulranzen suchen
rückläufig und jetzt die hausaufgaben
und damit diese gewisse lehrer kommt
nehme ich habe
immer
cool also von apple
erstens muss ab sofort jedes einzelne
feld musste statt seines nichts mehr
überwacht so ich habe die schätze
vergessen
das macht lied no sense
aber einer mandanten ok
[Musik]
also ganz kurz zwischenbilanz sie hat 60
goldblum du hast
er hat auch
130 habe null
[Musik]
also werden also schatz
den wir uns
echt mega geil und ihr könnt ihr jetzt
sogar aufpassen kann er kostenlos wie
genau das erzähle ich euch gleich aber
jetzt erst mal 3 1 spielen gibt es
gewisse regeln und eigenschaften dieses
relativ berechenbar machen welches
verhalten in gewissen situationen die
größte wahrscheinlichkeit hat zum ziel
zu führen die wissenschaft die sich
damit befassen wenn sich spieltheorie
und ihr habt euch schon gedacht das
funktioniert auch im echten leben beim
linke ist unserem heutigen sponsor habe
ich das buch juli für game schwierige
von es beschäftigt sich mit der
spieltheorie am beispiel vom
elfmeterschießen beim fußball und verrät
welche der beiden mannschaften eine um
50 prozent höhere gewinn
wahrscheinlichkeit hat als die andere je
nachdem ob sie zuerst schießt oder nicht
linke ist es bekannt dafür selbst die
dicksten melzer auf das wichtigste
herunterzubrechen damit gar nicht die
kernaussage von diesem buch in nur 13
minuten lesen beziehungsweise in meinem
fall anhören und das geht dann sogar ein
doppelter geschwindigkeit da blinkt es
gibt tausende bücher aus den kategorien
psychologie wissenschaft
persönlichkeitsentwicklung wirtschaft
und eigentlich allem was uns dabei hilft
das beste aus ihrem leben zu machen oder
uns auf die schule oder uni
vorzubereiten meldet euch jetzt anwalt
linke.de story und wird eine woche lang
in den spannendsten sachbüchern danach
könnt ihr euch entscheiden das abo zu
verlängern und behaltet über den link in
der mitte beschreibung sogar 25 prozent
rabatt auf das jahres-abo blick ist
bringen voll geil also ich finde es
waren megaerfolg tatsächlich hat richtig
spaß gemacht hat mega bock gemacht
übrigens hat alex der daviscup
programmierer sich richtig ins zeug
gelegt und ihr könnt das game jetzt
einfach über den link in der video
beschreibung irgendwo auch einmal
spielen haben so ein bisschen
überarbeitet dass es ein bisschen mehr
sinn macht also spielt das gerne mal
scheint jetzt findet man da natürlich
sagen abonniert gerne ist ein kanal
damit wenigsten verpasst sondern
zunächst macht's gut
[Musik]